Today in sha Allah as the conclusion
of the chapters regarding
purifying and najasa come to a close.
We have a very important principle.
That we are going to discuss
that will
conclude for us this chapter and this
topic.
So,
we were discussing for the past few days
how a person goes about purifying
something after a najasa has
contaminated it or come in contact with
it.
And the Prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam mentions a variety of things.
And when we look at all of those
narrations together from a bird's-eye
view,
we conclude two most important
principles.
Number one,
that purifying a najasa is relative.
So, what is clean for the ground is not
necessarily clean for the shoes is not
necessarily clean for the clothing, etc.
It is relative based on what it is that
we're cleaning.
Number two, and that is that by any
means
that the
najasa finds its way out of the clothing
or finds its way purified, it is
acceptable.
So, we are going to add a third
principle to that today.
And this
third principle will conclude this topic
here.
The author says, "Yesterday morning we
discussed the narration of Abu Hurairah
in which the
nomad, the Arab Arab Bedouin came
into the masjid and urinated in the
masjid. The Prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam commanded a the nub or a
a a bucket, a well bucket of water be
poured on the najasa, and it was then
considered to be cleaned by that."
Continuing from there, the author says,
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
Having technical difficulties here.
So,
the author says something very curious
here. He says, "And the prophet
told the companions
when that
Bedouin urinated in the masjid on that
incident incident
to put a bucket of water on it
in order to hasten the purity
purification of that
part of the ground in the masjid.
Otherwise,
if they had left it
and it had dried and completely
and
had dried to the point where it was it
was no longer detectable,
right?
Then, it would have been considered to
be cleaned by that.
Then it would and then he cites a
narration
that was mentioned by al-Bukhari
and it was narrated and reported by Abu
Dawud al-Sijistani on the authority of
Ibn Umar.
He says that
the stray dogs in Medina used to find
their way into the masjid and urinate
sometimes and come in and out of the
masjid when the masjid was empty
because, as we mentioned before,
the masjids didn't have any gates or
doors on it. It was open and so animals
would find their way, as they would,
into the masjid and they would do what
animals do. And the messenger of Allah
sallallahu alayhi wasallam didn't ever
say to put water on the place where
they may have urinated. Why? Because
it would have dried and it would have
been completely undetectable at that
point. There's no need for that. Now,
this takes us into a very interesting
point that the author goes into. He
says,
Well, hadha kalam makhudh min al-Muhalla
li-Ibn Hazm. Ibn Hazm rahimahullah fi
kitabih al-Muhalla bi al-athar yadhkuru
[Arabic recitation]
ijma' al-fuqaha' 'ala hadhihi
al-fuqaha' fi tanzili hadhihi al-qa'idah
'ala
ba'd al-mawadi' duna ba'd. Lakin,
al-qa'idah min haythu hiya qa'idah,
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
from Ibn Hazm.
he has a book
that is the only real reason why the
madhhab of the literalists is still
documented to this day.
And he was wrong on many issues. He was
correct on many issues in this book
Al-Muhalla.
He was correct on a great deal and many
of them.
And the issue with the literalists,
which the which is a group
of fukaha
that were extreme
in their
affirmation of the literal only.
so it's a group and and a madhhab.
And some of these scholars consider it
the fifth madhhab.
It is a group that were very literal.
They're called the Zahiriyah. And
they're so extreme in the literal
aspects of the Quran and Sunnah
that they overlook a lot of other
things. And the thing with extremists
and the the thing with extremism in
general
is when they're really when they're
wrong, they're really wrong.
But when they're right,
they're very right, okay?
And this is why al-Muhalla, authored by
Ibn Hazm, is still considered
a
can still considered a very esteemed
work in the science of fiqh, even though
it is catering to the Zahiri madhhab, it
is still has very strong points and
arguments and
very strong research in it, which was
proven to be invaluable to the Muslimeen
in the science of fiqh in the long run.
Now,
Ibn Hazm mentions in his book al-Muhalla
a principle called istihalah.
Al-istihalah,
the principle is as follows.
The ruling of Allah on a particular
thing
will change
if the nature of that thing changes.
This This called istihalah. Then he
gives examples.
He says for instance if an animal dies,
turns into a carcass,
and
months go by or weeks or or years and
the sun hits it and the wind and the
elements and so forth. Over time that
dead animal which is haram according to
the consensus of the fuqaha, over time
it will
turn into what? Turn into salt.
Right? Turn into salt. That salt, is it
haram
because of its origins or is that salt
halal now because the nature of that
dead animal has changed fundamentally
and now it has a new ruling with its new
form and that is the ruling of salt. The
answer is number two.
When something changes in its nature,
its ruling changes as well.
Another example. Let's say
you're at home and your neighbor
is barbecuing and you know, he's
non-Muslim, he throws some
pork onto the grill, right?
And as this fire hits the pork fat,
the pork and the pork fats is haram,
correct? And it is najis
according to consensus, it is considered
a type of najasa.
Well, when the fire hits
those molecules, what does it turn into?
What does it change it to?
What comes off of it?
Smoke.
Okay? That smoke,
what is that smoke? It's those molecules
changing
into that smoke. That smoke
bellows over to your side of the fence
and
it comes over your clothing, it comes
over your
Is that smoke najasa or not?
Is it najis or not?
The answer is no.
Why?
Because that is no longer pork.
That is no longer pig.
That is smoke.
And smoke is not considered a type of
najasa in any of its states.
Why did the ruling change? The ruling
changed when the nature of the thing
that was ruled upon changed.
Okay? And this also is something that
other
chemical processes
bring about. For instance, gelatin.
Take gelatin.
If I were to take gelatin
from plants and I were to take
gelatin from animals and go to a chemist
and say, "I want you to tell me
what kind of animal does gelatin came
from?
Or which one is the plant gelatin and
which one is the meat gelatin?" The
chemist would be unable to detect which
one is which.
Why? Because the nature of that thing
has changed on a chemical level. It has
changed. Therefore, the ruling has
changed along with it. This is called
istihala.
The scholars agree on this principle.
They agree
on the principle of istihala and that is
that
if the nature of a thing changes
fundamentally,
its ruling changes fundamentally.
Right? The only difference that they
have amongst them is
what
this ruling applies to as opposed to
what it doesn't apply to. So, you may
find some scholars differ on whether it
applies to gelatin or not, for instance.
Okay? They don't differ on the actual
principle, they differ on what?
On the application of the principle.
Does this case
warrant istihala or not? However, they
all agree on this principle. And this
This principle is very important. Why?
Because for instance, the water we drink
from the tap, where does it come from?
It comes from the
water purification
place, plant, right? Where all the bad
water that goes down the drain goes to
this plant, it's filtered, and it's
cured
we using chemicals and other processes,
and then it's pumped back through the
tap.
Now, was added was water added to that
water? No. It underwent chemical
processes
that changed it
in
its
fundamental state. So, we took sewage
water, which is najis,
and we cured it with chemicals and
different processes, and now when we
take it and test it, it no longer has
the same structure and makeup that that
sewage water had now.
Is this considered to be
pure or not? The answer is yes, it's
pure.
Even though the real way to purify water
that has najasa in it in Islamic fiqh is
how?
To add water to it. To continue to add
water until the najasa becomes so
diluted it is undetectable. Correct?
But the prophet salallahu alayhi
wasallam,
he has told us of a principle, of this
principle, and that is that
that water is not considered to be najis
because of a najasa that comes in
contact with it unless its color, taste,
or smell changes.
When its color, taste, or smell changes
due to that najasa, now it becomes
impure.
But then when we add water to it until
that is no longer detected and its color
goes back to its original state, and its
smell goes back to its original state,
and its taste goes back to its original
state, what happens now? It is pure
again, even though we know that there
was najasa in it.
But we added water until it was no
longer detectable, we took the water
back to its original state.
Now if we were to not add water, but
instead use chemicals or filtration or
whatever processes in order to make that
water no longer smell, no longer taste,
no longer discolored by the najasa, is
it now pure? Yes, it is pure. This is
This is
istihala in action. And that's why the
fuqaha of Islam agree that the water
that comes out of your tap is considered
to be pure.
And I have researched this, and there
are studies done on this, that this is
how
water is purified in these purification
plants. Is it valid? Yes, the fuqaha
agree
that modern fuqaha, they agree that this
is valid. Why? Because
the nature or the ruling of a thing
changes with the change of its
fundamental
state. Okay? That goes for anything.
Food, that goes for
let's say for instance and we'll give
one more example. Let's say a cook is
cooking
and he takes some wine and throws it on
the steak
as it's cooking, right? And so the wine
hits the steak, what happens to the wine
now?
The flame comes out, it burns
and then the taste, there's still a
taste left behind from the burnt wine.
However, is that wine still alcohol? The
answer is no.
The alcohol burned off.
The alcohol changed the nature.
If you ate 1 million steaks
just continued eating, one plate after
the other until you hit 1 million, would
you get drunk?
No, you won't get drunk, right?
You probably die from but you won't get
drunk. Why? Because the alcohol has
burned off. Is that steak halal or
haram? It is halal.
Now, again, keep in mind, we mentioned a
few weeks ago
what is halal is not always appropriate,
correct? Is it appropriate for a Muslim
to say bismillah al-rahman al-rahim,
throw some wine on my steak? That may
not be appropriate, but is it halal?
It is not haram. That is a different
thing altogether, correct? So this is
the ruling of istihala. It's extremely
beneficial to us as Muslimin.
The nature of istihala, this happens in
a lot of things, making of soap, the
making of food, gelatin, stuff that
that's in our food, that's in our water,
that's in the things that we use on our
body, the things that we use in our
clothes. These things are This ruling is
very important for us, and that is if
the fundamental of a thing changes, if
the fundamental state of a thing
changes, the ruling on that changes with
it. Right? With that, we will have ended
the chapters on taharat an-najasat, and
tomorrow inshallah, we will go into
sunan al-fitra.
Nas'al Allah inshallah, nas'al Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
an yufaqqihana fi dinina wa an
yu'allimana ma yanfa'una wa an yanfa'ana
bima allama bima allamana wa an
[Arabic recitation]